okay so June part 2 had its first
footage shown at Cinema con earlier in
the week Danny villanov's gone over
what's going to be in the movie shown
some footage and also discuss the
overall tone and aesthetic that they're
going for throughout this video we're
going to be going through what was said
at the presentation what was shown in
the trailer and also what we think will
be happening in the movie if you're
desperate for June content then we've
actually done a full video breaking down
Paula trady's entire story which
stretches through June all the way up to
its sequel Messiah and from there on to
the children of June however I will be
keeping the heavy spoilers at a minimum
for this video and instead just talking
about what moments the footage could be
alluding to if you enjoy the light
spoilers then please hit the thumbs up
button and don't forget to subscribe for
breakdown take this every day without
the way a huge thank you for clicking
this now let's get into June part two
[Music]
thank you
now June part 2 will be releasing
November this year and Denny stated that
the movie will pick up instantly after
the events of the first film that closed
out with Paul being brought into the
fold of the fremin so that they could
Mount up an offensive on the hawkcon in
house who'd killed his father and their
friends we ended with Paul seeing a
fremin soldier riding on top of a sand
worm and this will be something that the
character himself learns to do early on
now according to people at the event we
see the character attracting one of the
gigantic beasts through using a thumper
as he got closer Paul readied a pair of
boots and though he almost got killed he
managed to get on top of it at this
point he started his training and we saw
him taming the gigantic worm alongside
him will of course also be Zendaya's
Chaney in the first film she appeared
mainly through visions and dreams with
Paul finally meeting her come the end of
the movie the relationship between them
will take center stage in this film and
apparently the trailer itself opened
with the pair sitting together and
Talking Paul was discussing his life
back on kalidan and the vast blankets of
water that covered the planet Jenny had
never heard of anything like this and
her mind was blown by him explaining
swimming and also diving meanwhile she
hates San because it gets everywhere but
this gives her the idea that there's
something incredible about Paul now I
wasn't able to confirm whether this was
the case but I did hear from a couple of
people that we get some narration from
Florence Pew as we know she will be
playing princess Ireland which I always
pronounce her name wrong doesn't matter
but just in case you don't know she's
basically the emperor's daughter in the
1984 movie She provided some narration
there too and it looks like Denny's
giving an odd to that with her
potentially explaining the story we will
likely have some big time jumps in order
to cover everything and she might act as
a way to fill in all the story beats
apparently Pugh gets a great line in the
trailer and she says in the shadows of
Iraqis Sly many Secrets but the darkest
of them all may Remain the end of House
of tradies now I won't spoiler
connection Nepal but if you read the
book I've seen the 84 film then you'll
know she she ends up with a close tie
tomb as brought on by the emperor and we
know that he'll be played by none other
than Christopher Walken now on the other
side of this we saw Josh Brolin's
Journey Hallock reuniting with Paul and
Lady Jessica apparently the footage at
the event didn't have much of him and it
was basically put in place to confirm
that he did indeed survive the initial
attack by the house and make his way out
into the desert Gurney spent several
years on Iraqis and eventually he became
the leader of a group of Smugglers which
is when they clash with the fremin Paul
recognized him and thus they joined
forces rather than destroying each other
now with Lady Jessica it also looks like
they're bringing a big part of the book
in as well in the trailer we apparently
got Rebecca Ferguson riding in agony
which seemingly confirms that she'll be
going through the ritual let Caesar
become a reverend mother this is so she
can be elevated within the Benny Jesuit
and it's a nice way that I think they're
gonna take the movie now Jessica
apparently arrived around with her head
moving back and forth until we got a
shot of her eyes which turned to a dark
shade of blue there's lots of things
that happened with Jessica in the movie
as well and a big reveal about her
connection to the baron which will
likely be brought up in the film there
was no mention of it in the trailer
along with another reveal about her so
I'll save that in case you don't want to
know but they are going to be doing some
interesting things with her in the movie
now the baron will of course be
returning and along with him will be
fade who was absent from the first film
if you've seen the 80s version then this
guy was played by Sting rise in the
upcoming movie it's going to be Austin
Butler behind him they are really
hammering home how Ruth is and at the
event every shot of him was shown in
high contrast black and white from the
way it was described it kind of reminded
me of the scene with Goran tholav in
Thunder and rather than having a thick
head of Ginger hair he's gonna be bald
this is of course done so he fits in
with the rest of the harkonens and he's
apparently meant to bring across a very
imposing figure now I did try and find
out whether the other hardcoreans
featured in the trailer but all I could
find were things about fade he
apparently had a big knife fight with
Paul and the movie and this is supposed
to reflect the one at the end of the
first film now Danny said at the event
that the tone of part two's all at War
and that it'll have lots of action
scenes rather than a slower Pace the
director also confirmed that the entire
movie shot an IMAX so let's hope they
actually added to the physical media
release mate because you cheaped out on
that last 4K drop you cheaped out you
son of a
now unfortunately we don't get to see
that battle playing out but the trailer
did end with a teaser of where things
were going apparently the final shot of
it had Paul standing on the edge of a
giant cliff and at this point he pulled
his knife out he then held it up to his
head and the camera panned down to show
thousands of fremins standing below and
ready for battle I think that this will
end up being the final charge before it
all goes down and if you've read the
book you'll know that Paul learns a lot
about the fremin early on including the
vast numbers the indigenous people of
the planet have been held down by the
emperor for decades and he of course
also set up the Israeli so that they
died due to them opposing him as Paul's
attempting to lead the forces of the
planet against the Haw Conan so that he
can take it back and then Mount up
against the emperor doesn't bully all
play out that way but yeah there are the
things that we learned about the film at
the event this trial has been described
as jaw dropping and we know that Han
Zimmer will be returning to the film to
compose its score once more adeni said
he'd be interested in making a third
film based around Messiah which is the
book's direct follow-up he also hinted
at having plans for a television
spin-off series but it all depends on
the success of this movie therefore I'm
guessing that this film might end on a
cliffhanger with a somewhat conclusive
ending but still room for things to grow
the ending of Junior does seem like it's
quite a happy one but once you start
getting into the other chapters you get
the idea that things aren't all that
cracked up to be June is very much about
the fallacy of following people and how
those promise to be the next Messiah
could end up being anything but very
good subtext in it showing how power can
corrupt people and also how leaders are
often engineered by outside forces so
that they can lead people in thus give
those that seek power a way to control
the people on mass I really hope those
themes are explored in the film as I
think it would be such a cool way to
take things as we go down the line now I
am very hyped for this film as I'm sure
you can guess I think that June has the
potential to be one of the biggest
movies of the air I can't wait to see
how it builds off the back of that first
film and from the sounds of it they're
upping the ante in almost every way now
I hope you enjoyed the breakdown and if
you did then make sure you let me know
your thoughts on the film along with
what you want to see happening in it if
you read the books or if you're a newbie
I'd love to know so make sure you drop
your thoughts in the comments section
below and we are running in competition
right now and giving away the
quantumania steel Buck to three
subscribers on the 15th of May and all
you have to do to be on the chance of
winning is like the video make sure you
subscribe with notifications on and drop
a comment below with your thoughts on
the movie we will be picking the
comments at random on the 15th and the
winners of the last one are on screen
right now save that to you then message
me on Twitter at heavy spoilers if you
want something else to watch then we've
got a breakdown of The Flash trailer on
screen right now and also one for Craven
the hunter that was shown at Cinema con
and though it's not been released online
there are a lot of things that we
learned in it so yeah if you want to
know head over there if not then thanks
for sticking through the video I've been
Paul and I hope to see you next time you
take care peace
foreign